[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 191 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mark merchandani and I'm here with my
colleague and guest host Gabe Weiss hey
Gabe I see time show you hey Mark
hey Gabe how's it going it's going well
how are you I'm doing well I'm glad to
be here I'm super excited to have you on
you know came and I get to work together
every once in a while but then we got a
really cool chance to interview one of
the customers that Gabe was working with
called her Dax yeah they're awesome
so we have an interview coming up with
Ron and Austin talking about what her
decks is and some of the really cool
things are doing with collecting data
and working with Google cloud very very
excited to get into that and how it's
gonna save the world like that's the
exciting part for me like they're
totally gonna save the world I mean it's
such a grand gesture they're trying to
put into place and say look we know a
way to stop these common problems with
ranching solutions right you've got like
overmedication being an issue you've got
like introducing new bacterial things
you've got measuring all these kind of
data it's a really really cool interview
so I don't want to spoil too much we
will get into that yeah but before we
get into that I know since you're here
and you kind of know the IOT space
pretty well I do I've got a fun question
for you talking about how to connect an
IOT device to like a trigger event in
the cloud yeah so this it's the idea of
having a physical device in the world
responding from the cloud based on
sometimes automatic data sometimes a
trigger that you've done and it's it
turns out it's super easy to do okay we
have this cool product it's called IOT
core well let's get into that yeah but
before we even do that let's talk about
our cool things of the week
[Applause]
cuz there are some cool things on there
oh so many cool things alright what's
the first cool thing mark
well my first cool thing is that Google
has added an integration where you can
easily find podcasts you may be familiar
with podcasts I don't want to make
assumptions you might be listening to
this on an old ham radio I don't know if
someone's refried casting it but if you
haven't heard this is a podcast and now
when you type in certain search terms
into Google it will recommend podcasts
for you whoa so I can actually like
search for podcasts kind of like search
for images now you can just say hey find
me a cool podcast yeah you can be like
look give me slow-cooking podcasts and
bad that's the reference they use here
in the blog post but that's a super cool
thing and I think it's been rolled out
so go to Google type in cloud podcasts
and hopefully we come up I'm gonna see
if that works right what do we really
disappointed it's very mad at work wait
wait typing it in there it is the
podcast section specifically for us nice
oh good
all right well if you host a podcast or
if you listen to podcasts which I think
most people do probably at least all of
our listeners then that'll be a cool
feature to check out awesome I actually
want to I'm about to get a 3d printer
and I need to find podcasts about 3d
printing well I got great news go to
Google type in 3d printer I'm not gonna
do right now so what's your cool thing
alright so the cool thing that I found
being in the IOT space still there is a
group of researchers in Japan gonna
butcher the name it's keio university if
they have built a tail a tail for humans
a human tail right it's a robotic tail
and what they say they use for it is now
I can think of a bajillion uses for this
but the use that they're specifically
going after is to keep elderly people
upright interstate so the way that it
works is just the same way as a tail
does in nature which is to
counterbalance the rest of the body so
you know like cats can do all kinds of
crazy stuff they balance all sort of
weirdly and if their tail that allows
them to do that the tail kind of flares
out and offsets the weight of their body
the idea that they're positing is they
can attach this tail to humans and it
understands the position of your body
and offsets it they got some really cool
YouTube videos of like people using this
tail it's really I mean it's so
interesting but it just it keeps making
me think about like the inevitable
exoskeleton future where we're all just
running around in mechs
that's already kind of happening right
you knew this like that's happening but
those mech suits didn't have a tail
until now they should well they will now
this University's gonna make it happen
it's really cool it's very very
interesting I mean it's the it's cool
what people come up with and like that's
a great use case right because some
people who can't balance well I like
well what's a great way to do that but
also it sounds like have a little bit of
fun with it sure and use the concepts
brought up in nature I wonder if it
responds to your emotions oh that's
probably like v2 kind of stuff well
speaking of nothing to do with IRT I
think one of the cool things is a blog
post that just came out talking a little
bit more about how you can measure costs
now if you're doing something like
building giant robot tails there might
be a lot of costs associated with that
and the Google Cloud billing part of the
console can be a little intimidating
especially for people who are more
concerned with code and you know just
they want to get in there and they want
to run stuff right not necessarily
understanding how to pay for it well it
turns out at the end you still need to
pay for it so this blog post really
highlights some cool features that have
been released including some updates to
the billing reports a new kind of report
that lets you see a very very quick view
of what you're paying what your taxes
are what your discounts are and I think
the idea here is really letting people
get more observability on to what
they're paying for and better understand
it so that they don't spend as much time
trying to track down oh where you know
where did this payment come from I have
no idea what project this is all these
kind of things anything that makes that
process easier means you can go back to
doing the fun stuff quicker interesting
so is it kind of like a Google Wallet
add-on almost where it like kind of can
help you watch what you're spending like
well you can set up budgets for your
billing account you know I'm certainly
working with the billing team and
there's going to be some content coming
out soon that helps people understand
more about what you can do with the
billing reports suite we're not building
reports but actually the billing the
billing itself yeah yeah the whole the
whole thing setting up an account
setting up quotas and budgets on it and
understanding all those kind of things
all from within the GCP cons that's cool
because I've seen the calculator you
know we have that calculator for cost
and it's like a bajillion tabs because
each product has its own tab and each
tab has like a dozen things that you
have to know about your system like oh
okay I need to know how much network
traffic I've got why I'm gonna throw in
a bunch of terabytes because I don't
know and that kind of spits out a
monthly number so is this kind of a way
to help automate a little bit and kind
of help
people guide to figuring that out it's
gonna be a little bit more on the post
side so like after you spending this
money you have a better idea of where it
was projects and what resources is on
but the idea here is that with these
tools in place you should be able to put
better cost controls and really do cost
optimization and management so that you
don't have on you know surprising things
and that you can actually do predictions
like that
totally there is that GCP pricing
calculator you can use ahead of time to
kind of estimate a ballpark yeah yeah
it's a ballpark what you're gonna be
spending on I think it's got a lot of
features but I think you know here we're
talking about more stuff like measuring
where your cost postmortem it sure yeah
cool very very cool so some variety cool
things of the week but I don't want to
hold back the the main interview any
longer so let's go ahead and jump into
it with Ron and Austin
[Music]
super excited to have our guests Ron and
Austin here as we get started tell us
who you are and what you do I'm Ron
Hicks I'm the founder CEO of heard X and
this is our CTO Austin yep
so first questions first what is heard X
heard X is a fabulous idea if I can say
that self proclaimed somewhat biased but
I will be honest I came out of
retirement to do what I hope would be a
change for livestock across the world
one was to become an environmentally
friendly solution not easy to address
but something we feel like we've
accomplished so heard X is a third-party
provider a way in which we can take
livestock improve the system and bring
it to a consumer and improve the
transparency that's basically heard X so
that's a pretty broad statement what
does that actually entail for the
livestock especially so it's a big
change
so livestock in general is I would call
less transparent by design they're
typically animals raised in areas that
are very very isolated and by design it
has to be because they're out in the
middle of nowhere
so they're somewhat hidden in general
they're pretty good ranches out there
pretty good feed Lots and they have no
real way of broadcasting a positive
performance animal so the goal for heard
X is to authenticate that through data
so how does it do it like I first talked
to you I looked at my email to find out
exactly how long for chatting it's it's
been over a year now so June of 2018 was
kind of our first contact and at the
time you were describing kind of the
vision part of it but mechanically like
what is it about livestock you know you
know I have had a lot of conversations
about what it does and we know in a part
of it is that transparency too even all
the way to the end consumer so how does
it do that that's what we're kind of
looking for us like yeah yeah what does
this system do so they're probably steps
on there I think the initial approach is
you know what was working 50 years ago
what worked a hundred years ago and if
you look back you'll see kind of an art
to raising animals even in a more
quarantined or confined area and it was
this pin rider you had this gentleman
that would show up you know long-sleeve
shirt he was kind of the premier dude
that of the day and he'd come in and he
would cut through cattle his goal to
find animals they were
somewhat of a what we'll call an anomaly
if he could separate that one animal
than he could determine that that animal
may need some additional assistance
maybe check and see if there's a champ
some other things they don't have that
today so if you look for a pin rudder
it's the rarest of the cattle raised
what I would call key to good animals
what we're doing at herd X's we're
replacing that with data so the pen
writer was like a person it's like a
physical person they would get down into
the herds and like walk amongst the
animal and back alright this this cow or
this unit lamb or whatever they're
acting a little strange let's pull them
out of the herd and let's do something
so that's been replaced now by Watchers
mass antibiotics right like that's the
answers we'll just premedicate all of
our animals and who cares if they're
sick doesn't matter they're not gonna
infect anything because they're all
medicated they're medicated you're not
going to cross contaminate it's an easy
management decision again there's less
information so you cover it I think the
beauty of heard X type system is you
show an animals movement if that anomaly
occurs you go back to basically in time
a more natural method and you've
automated the entire system I saw
brasstacks now you talk about the herd X
automated system mm-hmm I don't want to
you know infringe upon any IP here like
so if there's there's company secrets I
don't want to touch on that but what is
the herd X system like how it so there's
no pin there's no pin man anymore right
that's right yeah so what is the system
do so we have monitoring solutions that
are deployed out at the feedlot that are
able to monitor the animals movement to
food and water and through that with
different algorithms in the processing
of their movement data and their
movement to water to food as opposed to
each other we're able to detect who's
the anomaly and as that system grows
we're also able to detect the you know
kind of forecast anomalies in different
breeds and in different weather
scenarios and things like that what's an
example of an anomaly so an example of
an anomaly is once you understand the
supply chain of cattle is many animals
are coming across the border from Mexico
or across several states on trucks and
they were weaned off of their mother so
they're off of milk and onto water and
grain so they're just a big transition
in a life so there's a lot of stress so
those animals might not be exhibiting a
temperature which is a fever or Indic
of some immune response in the animal
which is trying to fight a bacterial
infection or some stress response in the
animal but they might be moving weirdly
meaning they might spend a lot of time
laying down or they might not go to the
water trough as often as other people or
they might not go to food as often and
you know there's a lot of noise in the
air based on temperature and things like
that so that's why the pin writer was
kind of an art form because it was a
human brain able to filter out the noise
and understand this is an animal it
needs help I can see by the way its lips
look that it needs water and it hasn't
gone to the water trough because they
can't watch them all day like our
systems can so our system doesn't need
to know what the temperature of the
animal is that we can actually see their
movement and decide a couple of days
before they even have a temperature that
this animal needs to be pulled and taken
care of and what taken care of can mean
has just put on some lower stress sort
of behavior meaning get them away from
other animals for a while give them give
them the the actual load of antibiotics
maybe that they actually need so not a
mass treat but a specific acute sort of
treatment so collecting a tremendous
amount of data per animal and then you
multiply that by the number of animals
and you probably end up seeing a lot of
gigs or terabytes of just raw data and
then using that to kind of make
predictions and then I'm standing there
something's off here let's treat that
specific case with a much more strategic
implementation rather than just kind of
a broad hey let's just throw a bunch of
pills at the cows and see what happens
yeah yeah you know the prediction are
you actually using like machine learning
and artificial intelligence to do that
you're actually training all of the
models yeah and that that's part of
where GCP comes in as we've been able to
throw large volumes of that behavioral
data into you know systems like bigquery
and cloud dataflow and able to run model
so for that so that we can you know and
also test different models to see what
sort of negatives they would generate to
understand how we can continue to grow
and learn this thing over time as the
system gets smarter with putting in
breed data putting in other different
variables that could affect the outcome
of the animal which are all things that
these feedlots are trying to do with
their food but they're not looking at it
from a health perspective they're going
out of their way to decide what's the
most effective food so that they can
spend the least amount of food for the
largest amount
weight gain because I mean that's what a
feedlot is in totally it sounds horrible
but really it can be done in a very
humane way and there's a lot of them
that do it in a humane way but it gets
hidden by you know one bad actor so it's
all trade offs right like you're you're
trading off as harsh as this is gonna
sound be trading off a certain amount of
humanity for really the business I mean
ultimately they're all ranchers they're
all in it for their business that's what
they do so I can imagine that there's a
lot of kind of trade-off when you're
talking about that so the cool thing for
me and like why I got interested in her
decks when I first chatted was this
feels like a way to mitigate that
trade-off like you can still be humane
with these animals but still get the
gains and the you know the profitability
so you can like you said transform the
industry right that's kind of the ideas
how can do that so when did you know you
had something like you had this idea you
came out of retirement for it what was
that like the magical moment where you
said this could work like we've got
something here I think what you were
actually involved somewhat in that early
stage we took over a small feed law at
least it decided just like any
disruptive product which is really my
past in order to change the mindset
you've got to prove it and so here I'm
coming in really unbiased no background
on raising livestock in fact to be
honest with you I'm not someone that
really likes something that's not clean
asked my wife I mean everything is
sterile at my home and so moving out to
a feedlot area leasing something from a
very famous style set of leaders that in
the past have done very very well this
place was abandoned so we went in and
said okay we're gonna bring animals in
we're gonna test we're gonna try some
things all with natural means using data
and the woman that was there was
watching this and leased this property
to us started to become very excited
again when I first went out there she
probably thought we were nuts and she
began to say look this is interesting
was she a rancher herself she was a past
rancher so they had basically given up
on the process of the feedlots a lot of
the family had moved out it's also very
common the younger generation decides to
move to the city and do other things so
you'll see that older generation trying
to hang on but how do you do that
without maybe the labor force or the
means so we went in and just decided
we'll just make it our own ranch and
we'll create our own feedlot and you
would never ranch before never so this
was like totally fresh I'm gonna come in
I'm just gonna make a ranch how hard
could it be
it was harder than we thought but I
think the issue is we realized if we do
this in a way which we would call it the
most humane way of raising animal using
natural means and bringing in these tech
systems that we were just going to place
out there and start to test even the
rancher herself said I thought you were
in a different world and said I think
this is something that I'd like to
actually participate in and if you
remember you met with her she went nuts
with the lunch and at the lunch yeah
yeah almost a year ago like almost
exactly a year ago no and she was proud
of the actual output of what we could
call a high performance animal never
needed medicine gained weight
beautifully and was absolutely
incredible the flavor everything about
it I'm remembering who remember this I
mean we're talking about the middle of a
bell curve here that's the primary beef
in this country is feedlot raised so we
changed the basis of feed Lots with
someone that never seen it before and
she ends up becoming a superstar sold
everything immediately all the animals
were sold so she's in the practice now
of actually being one of the top well I
would call high tech ranchers just by
the sheer fact that we drove by one day
and leased her place that's awesome I
love that you told me a story at one
point which I would love for you to
regale us with of when you were kind of
testing the AI system against humans it
was like masters students and veterinary
system he was like yeah prove that your
system could predict as accurately as
they could
Austin's talking about anomalies or what
we call something that's odd and I think
that you guys here Google understand
this if you can take in enough data you
can really see a lot but if you go into
an area that's not ever been watched you
can surprise some of the best in the
world and and we went out to meet with
some of the high end vets that actually
do feel ah man ajma'in they said Ron we
have a graduating class and in the
summer we always make the graduates work
through the final year and we do stuff
like test them can we test you with our
graduates we are the best and these
graduates are what we consider to be
some of the top so they've made it
through the program bring your stuff out
let's watch some animals and you let us
know what you think
we literally sip the antennas up no one
told us anything we drove away
we're probably 500 yards from the site
and we could see from our system the
animal that was without a doubt in
trouble a system knew the system knew
yeah yeah we were actually embarrassed
because we knew so quickly so our chief
engineer said we need to go back and
tell them
said we need to wait about 30 minutes so
you said you knew within a minute or
seconds oh yeah you're just like oh
that's the problem one but we can't go
back and embarrass them we're sitting in
a suburban up the road we didn't want to
turn around because I was embarrassed
myself for the poor students who were
out there with their notebooks and
trying to look almost like a pen writer
would because that's a very strong point
here a pin router can give you one
viewpoint sure but if you look at date
on a general basis and it's
recalculating and reformatting it
doesn't take long for us to see what
comes to the top and we did it she just
go driving circles for a bit before he
came back we did yeah he did we picked
up some barbecue at a little place here
I'm again I'm not a big ranch type
person so walked in and got some
barbecue stalled went back to the lot
told the vets we know the animal and we
obviously put on a little piece paper
handed to him he's shocked he's trying
to slow it down but he said to those
students let's come in they turned in
their results we turn in ours we were
the only correct answer hmm the only one
that's unfortunate for them but if it's
hard right like that is the reality of
this situation is that it can be really
difficult to observe these sorts of
things and being able to collect like
you said earlier tremendous amounts of
data and then make predictions on it is
something that just hasn't been possible
up until recently that's right I mean
spin writers have like the lifetime of
doing the job right now they've got just
a lifetime of experience of gathering
that data so in essence they're kind of
like you know the hard drives or you
know when at the storage where we want
to you want to call it one and one of
them retire there's all that tribal
knowledge just going on it's so cool to
me that there is no leaving the system
like the data is there the data is there
so it's really more of a factor of like
this can just be applied everywhere
there's no reason not to just apply this
all over it's way more possible to
export a model like from AI that would
be from a person human knowledge is
tough to dump like and you know anyone
that's left a job knows like I've got
two weeks and dump all of my knowledge
like that's not a thing you do that
can't do that if you're looking for
another business idea finding a way to
XQ Minh trained models an ambassador so
on that are you we we can't discount the
years of experience that the pen writers
that do still work in feedlots so we
have built features into our you know
ecosystem apps whatever you call them
that do allow human feedback so
we'll make what we call a prediction or
a recommendation right but we still
allow and track the negation or
acceptance of that from an actual pen
writer I'm guessing that then that gets
folded into the model yes a lot of
people are aware you know machine
learning you have to put weights on
things it's big weighted average
machines just churning at high speed
right so you know you put a specific
weight on that feature or that data
point and and it can get folded in so
it's a function of understanding how
important the different variables are in
different cases and then making good
predictions that are not you know noisy
they're not you know false positives and
they're also manageable by the staff
because when you go into a feedlot that
might be really not doing so great you
need a lot more antibiotics maybe or in
the sense of you know being able to
provide you know relevant and and
manageable predictions so we have this
concept of you know a green field versus
brown field the idea is does your system
work you mentioned like a feedlot that's
in bad shape and you know like lots of
sick animals or whatever it is can the
system be deployed and fixed brown field
so you could like take a feedlot like
that that's in a really bad shape and be
like hey bring in our system it will
help fix your situation can do that oh
yeah yeah we think that if you deploy
our system or monitoring in the right
way on a feedlot like that if you have a
good strategy for treating those animals
which we have a couple of other
technologies that can help you with that
we think you could turn that place
around and I think there's evidence of
that in some past research that Ron and
people before me have done yeah and
that's kind of the idea here is not to
completely automate the entire farm
right the idea or the ranch in this case
the idea here is to actually gather all
of this data which wasn't possible
before make predictions on this data
which wasn't really possible for - human
intuition which is an astoundingly
powerful thing but like you said it's
difficult to export it's difficult to
transfer that to different people but
it's also limited in terms of what one
person who comes in and sees it is so
with your system you collect all the
data you make the prediction and then
you give it to the humans and you know
they can implement changes based on that
right like a lot of AI it's not trying
to replace humans it's trying to make
them much more efficient at not only
getting but also predicting based on the
data that just wasn't possible yeah I
mean if you think about the fact that we
showed an early tool to university it's
great at what they do that tool becomes
better
as soon as the input is I think shared
across a number of users it even
improves through the human interface
it's artificial intelligence right so
the idea is the more inputs you get the
better the system gets more accurate
gets so broader adoption just means it's
gonna be better and better at predicting
the anomalies of an animal that's not
behaving properly it's just gonna get
better doing that and this is something
I think we should maybe talk a little
bit about the whole global impact if you
can imagine now converging information
from different parts of the world
looking at different animal movement
criteria you're talking about global
perspectives here and I think we can
automate a really nice system based on
the fact that there's a desire to have
animals that are high-performance clean
and retailed properly because we're
bringing the transparency now to the
retailer and I imagine that you know
these models have a lot in common but
how different is that data from a ranch
in Texas versus like a ranch in let's
say Australia it's so the difference I
mean Austin could go to this but we
obviously have environmental changes and
obviously the breed the genetics
surprisingly the fact that movement is
so vital to an animal right especially
if they're in a stress condition is
somewhat similar but you've got all the
other pieces that come into play so a
stress situation might look very
different in a hot humid environment
like Texas versus you know they say an
arid noisy situation oh yeah
day one implementing if we australia and
somewhere in wyoming whatever totally
different temperature we can still
predict the animals that are sick just
on the way they move the goal is to get
better and better at that adding in the
other variable and better and better
translates do like that do better better
better how fast also being able to
filter out any noise that we might be
creating based on other factors such as
you know a different terrain blah blah
blah things like that or or heat
humidity levels the moisture content of
the grass or their food different things
like that so those are some of those
variables but given you know the
difference of hours or days on their
behavior we can still predict which ones
are sick so and that's been proven for
through different temperature scenarios
and things like that that again the
research said early heard x did so a lot
of what's happened in hurt x is amazing
technology and ideas have been developed
and now the phase that were in now is
actually taking that realizing the data
value of it bring it into the cloud and
scaling that piece so a lot of this cool
stuff has actually been implemented on
farms and things like that and what
we've now doing is packaging it up where
it can be run in a modern way and on the
cloud and scale out to the entire globe
we call that the lift and shift yeah
yeah like once you've got it all set up
in it in your local environment you have
it all humming along now it's time to
get rid of structured requirements just
get it out so I know that we've been
talking a lot about the first part of
this business but I know there's more
yeah you talked about original you know
this the transparency all the way to the
consumer so let's talk a little bit
about like what that means we've now got
a good idea of what it looks like on the
ranch right so we've got the live stocks
all being taken care if they're getting
you know improved health conditions on
the feed Lots how does this help the
consumer where does the consumer come
into this story for her next I mean all
said I can both jump into this it's kind
of fund we've been watching this happen
over the last year for him and the last
five years for me the retail experience
is radically different than it was five
years ago the amount of data that's
necessary to make a purchase has to be
high-speed and has to be relevant right
so your buyer is more aware in certain
categories of food as to what they're
eating and how it was raised in the case
of us beef that's our goal now is to
really bring that transparency all the
way through a we'll call it a blockchain
perspective but it's the methodology of
participants that all work to make sure
that the food is high-end treated in a
more natural way in the beginning and
then processed in the best conditions
and then moved and trucked under the
right conditions by putting all those
pieces together you've created a really
awesome system for retailers it feels
like and correct me if I'm wrong you
know the concept of the farm-to-table
right like that's what we're talking
about is people are really enamored of
the farm-to-table concept of knowing
like this food came from the farm a mile
away so it sounds like what you're kind
of in essence doing is extending the
reach the range of what that
farm-to-table means the food doesn't
have to be next door to you anymore it
can be you know to ranch hundreds of
miles away but you're giving kind of the
ability to see for those end consumers
what the origin point kind of looks like
and what's from what does that look like
for the sooner I'm gonna go buy some
meat yep right let's do this in a way in
which I think Austin can help break this
down from a market perspective or maybe
the niche
her necks has I think there's a given on
anything that's pasture-raised that's
out there just running and roaming it's
a good animal it has not been removed
from its mom it's running out at a
really well-run pasture so it's that the
given is it's safe it's clean it's a
great animal high performance when I'm
saying that it's a high performance and
good in the case of the feedlot again
the majority of the entire us business
right 24 million animals on feed here in
the US today
how do you take care of those so that's
what the system is all about and I think
the advantage is it's the majority of
this country's livestock and beef that's
raised on a feedlot that is not a
pasture raised animal and that's what
we're basically putting a mechanism in
place to allow that to be the future of
how beef will be raised and how it's
made available to the retailer yeah so
we analyzed the cattle supply chain you
know the meat supply chain and looking
at the different countries involved and
they all want a tracing program and
there's so many hurdles to that and you
know people who don't want to share data
with who or people who are kind of on
the fringe of the supply chain so we
selected kind of the technology and the
methodology of just having each person
just have a way to manage the
transaction on the batch of animals
right although we can with the data
we're not trying to be one of those
people that shows you the nose print of
the cow that you're eating we don't
think that the consumer really is in it
a bit much yeah I think what the
consumer wants is a connection with
another person not a connection with an
animal the rancher yeah yeah I mean so
we're trying to basically lift the
rancher the producer where the animal
has been most of its life because
they're only at a feedlot for maybe
three months maybe five months so the
majority of its life it was raised as a
great animal on a pasture in some small
town with some just super quality people
and then it gets moved into the supply
chain that where it gets hidden and
those people you know they're having to
fight for business all the time so we're
trying to highlight those people create
more incentive for people to have longer
term contracts with each other because
they're working together on a supply
chain which ends up making them all more
profitable while at the same time not
changing the middle of the bell curve of
meat because we want basically the
pasture raised farm-to-table for every
family we want that for everyone
so how we do it is we outfit the
different supply chain partners or we
integrate with technology so we
integrate with their technology we
outfit them with technology and they're
able to check in check out kind of at
that transaction time at the moment of
transaction where the animal or the
product is moving hands we're able to
take their paper processes make them
digital but then because it's going into
a you know distributed ledger because I
hate the word blockchain it's something
that we're trying to build for 50 years
to come right we're trying to select a
technology that's future ish proof right
something that can be managed by the
industry moving forward that's the
reason for the distributed nature of it
it's not because blockchain is the hot
thing it's because it actually makes
sense in this case because they'll will
start to manage the industry long after
maybe her decks in 20 years maybe her
decks isn't a thing who knows but the
cattle industry all over the world needs
a distributed method for having a single
source of truth because that's what the
consumers need and that's also what
agencies need health agencies need
people need in recall scenarios there's
a lot of what's the opposite of
collateral damage
yeah no I mean collateral you know
improvement when you when you get a
system that can know the source ranch
and all the steps in between that
something's taken because it's not the
producer that has a problem it's many
steps down the road and there any
changes of hands it could even be that
in a bad scenario obviously her Texas is
focused as technology is focused on
removing the bad animal before they get
into the supply chain that's a big huge
goal right but there's also the ability
to detect the issues within the supply
chain due to timing temperature control
things like that because a lot of times
it's just a package of meat sitting on
an airport because a truck is late you
know kind of a thing that's where
sometimes things go wrong and people get
sick and stuff like that and so what
we're hoping to do is first off remove
the bad animal at the beginning because
when you have a higher-quality animal
the shelf-life of that product is
actually better because of the stuff
inside the meat but then when it gets
into the supply chain kind of taking
away the hidden tactics that make that a
little less safe does that make sense
yeah of being able to backtrack if there
is a bad actor some
we're along the supply chain like I said
it might be you know a pallet that was
left for a little bit too long and now
everything in that pallets bad but
everything in that pallet might be
forked all over the place from different
ranchers if the ledger can identify from
all of the same meat back to one
bottleneck point you now know that's you
know you found here that actor so the
core of the health system of you know
watching over these animals that all
happens at the feedlot level but you're
saying this ledger the blockchain for
lack of a better way of putting it the
receipt of transfer extends all the way
back to the initial ranchers the raising
of the animals so it's like you know
raising the animals to the feed Lots to
the packing inch so you're tracking the
whole chain how far down does it go does
it go all the way to the end consumers
the stores how far does it go yeah I
mean so think of it backward so we're
working as hard as we can to get as
close to birth of the animal as we can I
mean the easier parts are starting at
the grocery store and working backward
so not that it's a huge challenge I'm
just saying the harder part is to get
propagated all the way back to these
ranches that are on 2g basically kind of
a thing so that's where we love our
business model because it pulls us into
those places so we don't have to go look
for them they're just you know we get an
address right basically kind of a thing
but it does go all the way to the
grocery store and that's really the
consumer side go ahead and right yeah I
mean the grocery is needing to make sure
they retain customers and so if you
think about it if you can actually
highlight a new meat product have a
story board back to a hot producer
you've completed the chain but in the
sense you've improved retail and so I
think there's a huge advantage again in
our case we recognize that when an
animal comes through it's divided into
many parts and so you've got some that
go to a restaurant some that goes to a
grocer some will be ground into ground
beef right and so the advantage for us
is providing that transparency all the
way through we believe that stash will
retail thrust of our company very
imagining a be testing with different
ranchers and like I know the me from
this Rancher is really where it's at but
what's interesting you're saying that I
mean I think it's a new market advantage
and I'm sure if some are listening today
that the retailer is always looking for
something right especially the big
market managers over there product
managers if you can imagine if we go
back to the ranch the original test
ranch of the meaning that I've had she
sold all of her meat immediately so if
you really ate at that restaurant that
night
and I think Gabe you're with us if you
think about a grocer up the street a
small grocer here in Austin that carries
that same brand they may ask for hers
again think about that on the backside
coming back so now we're providing a
report back to the producer who says we
need to have so many more of your
animals so much weight so many cuts to
come to this Austin grocer do to the
restaurant that was just up the road
well it's like you said right I mean
this is visible throughout the entire
supply chain and absolutely at each step
they're gonna look back and say I want
this one because this one has more data
you know I know this is good and here's
the reasons why it's good I now have
observability in ways that I didn't
before and that goes from all the way
from the ramp up all the way to the
person who goes and buys it whether
that's a restaurant whether that's a
just a person going to a grocery store
yeah the thrill I literally I'm this
even today or work with you guys we
could do this globally so I'm in New
Zealand I'm leave for Japan on Monday
I'm in New Zealand the following week
we're providing the same reports back to
them of requests for those animals that
has never been seen before we're
providing to the retailer reports of
information they've never seen before
we're marrying basically those two ents
another book in time soon as people are
super excited about seeing that like
that's that's got to be my opening for
these folks that's oh yeah I can I can
know what exactly how do i how like
that's the magic right that's that's it
that's totally that what's offered one
thing we talk about a lot with her Dex
is you know our Dex isn't the only one
that could implement a traceability
program there's a lot of people that are
trying to do it the USDA has been trying
for how long 21 years 21 years
we love the USDA and we think they can
do it and we are here to help right but
there's something different when you
have a supply chain that's also got what
we call authenticated data meaning data
that's collected without human
intervention or interaction so we have
automatic monitoring systems that can
verify the source country of the animal
that can verify a number of different
things it can actually also play into
however far we want to move the movement
data even over to the retailer to give
them a stamp of assurance or some form
of quality metrics on this animal when
you think about higher quality retailers
or when you think about retailers that
are just super risk-averse I'm thinking
of a name right
now they want as much date as they can
on mitigating their risk sure so they
want the highest quality lowest cost
animals right so the data that we're
able to provide but not just data but
authenticated data data that isn't just
someone scanning a piece of paper which
could be fraught with error its
authenticated data from automatic
monitoring systems that we actually know
if someone's opened the panel on our
hardware it's like you know we can put
different weights on different data so
we think that authenticated data or
thinking about data in a way that's like
hey this is not just manual data
digitized this is a new form of data
that didn't exist before and it's
collected in an autonomous way which I
think heightens your ability to trust it
because there's no human intervention
there's no bad actors available it's not
subjective anymore yeah it's not
subjective so this one yourself kind of
an interesting thought which is you know
the the USDA offers a bunch of
certifications like organic and all
these other things it kind of feels like
your system would kind of blow that all
the water because the certification
becomes automatic now if you know every
step of how your animals raised you know
if it's organically raised like there's
no more I don't have to give someone a
bunch of money to get the stamp on it
that says I'm organic anymore like have
you felt any pushback from that you go
to the grocer and you just have the
heard X number on there right yes
so I think some of those agencies aren't
necessarily aware of what this sort of
ledger the sort of network can do they
haven't put two and two together yet and
think about the fact that it could be
cooperative it couldn't be as bad as
what you're saying it can be a
cooperative thing with them that's part
of the goal of the network again is this
is for the industry obviously we're a
company we have to make money but this
is for the industry and you think about
the way that block chains can work I
mean we have our smart contract that
manages the change of hands on the
network but there's other contracts that
can be written on top of the same
network right so the organic
certification could be a function of
data in certification out on a specific
batch of meat so those are some of the
things that maybe you still have an
overhead cost or whatever this is just
ideation sure those are some things that
you can do with weird thing to say a
data network yeah you know a ledger so
how that works out is you know you have
third parties and agencies involved in
different
to the data because again the beauty of
the distributed ledger is not all the
data is in everyone's hands but the fact
that there's data somewhere is in
everyone's hands the world state is
distributed but not the actual data is
distributed it's right cool
again we've talked about this with you
guys that I believe Google brings a
tremendous amount of b2c information and
knowledge I mean I think we have to be
aware of the fact that Enterprise
Solutions information on the cloud on
multiple clouds whatever we're setting
up we feel really comfortable with the
fact that search is a very important
part of retail and I think it's
important that we as a company take
advantage of the fact that they're the
shoppers changed and that search and
what they read and some of the ad
campaigns that we're gonna place
together was with I think some of the
top grocers and restaurants in the world
all fit with this new data it totally
makes sense this is unique right like
there are so many people talking about
oh we can grab data and analyze it and
build machine learning and then what
right this is a concrete scenario where
you said look we know that we can do
this what are we gonna use it on and
then you found an actual case study or a
use case in this I should say and then
said yeah let's do it let's apply it
let's see what happens let's test it and
then now you're coming up with a
business model based on it and now
you're basically flying all over the
world trying to show people this is cool
and people care about it and we're
making animals healthier we're making
the supply chain easier to understand
we're giving consumer choices I mean
this is win win win win win so that I
think is really the core model
Austin's look at me because my main
thrust or every time I come to companies
everybody wins and we really feel like
that right even the USDA piece it often
commented on it's a win for them is it
cutting-edge it is I mean I spoke at the
conference they asked me to come and
speak I actually said I didn't have time
and I realized I'd better just go say
something because we could provide a
tremendous amount of information even if
as small as it might be that is just the
right piece for a recall they don't have
to pull two weeks of supplies they can
pull to one ten hours right the pallet
of me enough so maybe a batch that's it
well this has all been super cool I
think we're running out of time are
there any other events coming up what's
come
soon for her tax so I don't have to
sleep that's it some people say we love
the changes that are going on not only
in our industry but and many others due
to data my big event for me is the
innovator of the Year finalist in New
Zealand due to the fact that we're
taking all their sheep and lambs and
placing this technology out there and
helping them to propagate what they have
to propagate is a livestock export
business they have to keep that rolling
we're gonna basically build that we're
also nominated for bilateral trade which
is an increase in New Zealand's business
which has already happened due to our
product so those are the big wins for me
and actually it's a long flight but it's
well worth it when you can come up
against some of these guys that launch
rockets for a living and say we're
helping a launch sheep not launched
sheep in Rockets just wanna make sure
that's that's next year I kind of want
to know lunch know I kind of need to do
that right I think you need to make a
business model I mean you are the CTO
this can happen quantum computers cheap
rocket launchers yes it still uses the
blockchain yeah that's how you know it's
kind of got to keep the buzzword got to
keep the buzz word well Ron Austin thank
you so much for coming in and talking
about I mean this is this is fascinating
stuff so thank you so much for kind of
shedding some light on it and you know
obviously good luck at the innovator
Awards thank you thank you all thank you
so much to Ron and Austin and Gabe for
of course making that connection and
bringing them in I mean like there's a
whole world that had never even thought
of before I think Ron said it which was
when you go into like markets and
industries that haven't really looked at
the data it's fascinating what you can
get out of it once you can collect and
look at these huge amounts of data in
aggregate like what you can do with that
boggles my mind and I'm really glad that
her Dex was able to figure out like I'm
just gonna look at cow data and they
figured out this really cool system
based on just movement of cows this
really it's awesome yeah I mean it's a
cool system and like you said earlier
like it's such a great idea they have to
try and bring a little bit of
cleansiness a little bit more
responsibility a lot more observability
into the whole process so that
ultimately they're solving some real
problems and I know that Ron shared
stories that he's going off and
travelling and bringing this to a lot of
people so it's super exciting to see
where this will be in the next couple of
months
totally super super cool well we talked
a little bit earlier so let's revisit
our question of the week is and so let
me ask you know if I've got a physical
IOT device or some sort of like
mechanical servo or something and I want
it to respond to an event in the cloud
like let's say somebody uploads a file
or someone changes some parameter and
that causes a trigger what does it
actually look like those are two very
separate concepts yeah how does that
work so it's it's interesting it's not
as hard as you might think
so we've got a product for in Google
Cloud called IOT core and what it does
is it allows you to communicate between
a device in the cloud securely it
connects it in a secure way to the cloud
and now that physical device has a
digital representation in the industry
sometimes called at a digital twin they
have this digital object in the cloud
that you can kind of interact with and
there's api's where depending on how you
want to trigger it you can send admin
messages you know configuration messages
or commands back down to your device
through this connection so when the
device is online you can basically say
things like okay I want a fan to
automatically turn on when the
temperature hits a certain level so it's
easy if they're in proximity I've we've
all got like a thermostat in the house
right so the thermostat hits a certain
level and either your heater or your AC
comes on in the house same concept and I
can divorce it from being physically
connected so you don't have to have a
thermostat connected to your heater
system anymore
thermostats connect to the internet your
heaters connected to the Internet and
now based on the temperature on your
thermostat your furnace can come on so
this is the same idea of like you know
nest does this whether the smart stuff
setting all the data out that's kind of
the same idea of how you do this so from
a physical standpoint you've got some
input and that can be like temperature
going up to the cloud and those can be
messages going into cloud pub/sub and
then you've got something watching cloud
pub/sub that eats those messages and
send through the IOT core admin
interface that says for this device do
this and then I have two core reaches
out to that device through the digital
representation that's got and the device
responds to it so it's a pretty simple
by API as I mean it's like one function
call it's not like there's you know huge
amounts of code you have to write it's
really concise it's nice so IOT core
does a lot of the work there and it kind
of
two different parts it does the part
where it receives a signal which I think
you can call through pub/sub or some
other cloud functions which hopefully
most people who are working in the cloud
have a good sense of how to do and then
on the IOT core site it also creates a
digital version like you said a digital
twin that basically you're sending
signals to that and then when that gets
a signal it handles the mechanical part
of like connecting that to the actual
device so my product manager is gonna
freak out
digital twin has a very specific meaning
in a lot of places and this is not
technically like what the industry call
I think of it as digital twin because I
haven't been in the IT industry for like
decades but people that have been
there's a very specific connotation I
call it that but it's really just an
object in the cloud that represents you
know this physical device I wrote a blog
post about like literal step-by-step if
you wanted to do something like this I'm
Gabe Weiss on medium.com if you just
look for Gabe Weiss you'll find it
they're shown us we'll have a link to it
but yeah I basically came from the
concept of in the IOT world there's two
types of engineers there's hardware
engineers and software engineers and the
hardware engineers often have no idea
about the cloud this is a broad
generalization it's not always true but
like silk and hardware people often
don't understand the cloud and then
cloud people and software people often
have no idea about the physical devices
so I came at it from let's pretend no
knowledge let's pretend the people that
are coming to wanting to do this have no
idea how to do anything so it's step by
step very clear like you know run this
command make sure you see this output
like it's really the blog post I wrote
for this are very detailed on how to do
that so I mean if that's something you
know people are interested in go read
the blog post or just yell a game about
using digital twinning correct now yeah
I mean anything works but it sounds like
those are some that's some pretty cool
stuff I haven't gotten into this blog
post but maybe I'll spend the weekend
reading it's fun like it kind of opens
your mind to like well what can i
aughtta mate in my house what could i
and then do it safely please please
please please
test test test and then be certain
there's no like loose wires or anything
don't set the common fire no that's bad
but you usually I would say most people
can agree that's pretty bad right I mean
doc people I don't know so very very
cool to to check out those details I'll
definitely be looking at that in the
meantime Gabe what do you have going on
anything cool coming up Andy cool travel
or plans a couple things so I'm gonna be
a cloud next in London
in November just officially signed on
I'm moderating a panel on machine
learning which will be fun yeah I'm also
I'm going to talk to a potential
customer of ours they want to do some
IOT stuff there it's awesome they're
doing heavy IOT data on ocean current
temperatures and they've come up with
some cool tech to do the buoys better so
I'm gonna go chat with them about how to
get that data in the cloud there's
another example of like a lot of
companies figuring out now that we have
the ability to collect all this data and
now that we have the ability to process
all this data what could we do we can do
anything exactly that we just need to
figure out what it is and I'm sure that
you know measuring the temperature of
things like the ocean currents and what
direction they're going in and all those
other kind of data that I have no idea
about but all those kind of things it's
like well what can you do with right I'm
sure that the possibilities from they're
gonna be endless especially like the
energy space and in terms of like safety
all kinds of things from that I hope you
save the planet it's it's almost like
IOT is saving the planet Thank You GAE I
want that to be our new tackle you are
helping people save the planet
so what about you mark what you got
coming up I am NOT saving the planet
unfortunately I am going to stay pretty
local working on some like I mentioned
with the billing I think we're trying to
launch a couple of cool videos and other
content items to help people understand
a lot more about billing I'd like to
think that while people are using IOT to
save the planet I'm going to be helping
them make sure that they pay everything
responsibly and that they can keep their
costs down well it just it's important
because we need those companies to stay
around you need all of that you need
everything and they're still saving the
planet we're all working together to
save the planet well on that feel-good
note I think we're just about out of
time so thank you everyone for tuning in
and we'll see you all next week
[Music]
right before I go on stage I will feel
like I have to pee I could have gone P
two seconds before doesn't matter that's
how my nerves nervous bladder right yeah
yeah but I think that's something a lot
of people can really that's what I mean
like I just feel like it but I don't
have to go I could have just gone like
right right there's no pee there's no
pee